- Wow.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] So have y'all met before?
Y'all have worked together, right?
- We worked together.
- Yes, we did.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- With my very good friend
and late John Ritter.
Bless his soul.
- Yes.
- [Henry] That's the first time we met.
- And we met backstage.
- Yeah.
- I was gonna say did y'all meet?
(Kelly chuckling)
We go way back.
- We go way, way back
to like 25 minutes ago.
- Yes. What a full 25 minutes it's been.
- [Zosia] I know. Honestly, it feels
like a life time.
- Enjoying you out here.
- Did chemistry ignite with y'all as well,
your friendship?
- You know what, I have to tell you,
your conversation just now was amazing
because it was so relatable.
Whether man and woman,
it was so open and it
was like you were two
just sitting in your living room.
- Oh, that's what I want
the show to feel like.
- Well, that's what it felt like.
- Oh, good.
- Ah, that's so sweet.
- Okay. I've done my job.
- No!
(audience applauding)
No, I wanna talk!
How is your family?
How are your grandkids?
- Okay, okay. My-
- I love how excited
grandparents get about grandkids.
(Kelly laughing)
- But, okay, so we have six.
- Oh my God!
- And then newest is five months old.
- Oh, baby smell.
- Francis Joan,
and her mother and father
are bringing her tonight.
- Oh!
- Yes.
In order to have a vacation at our house.
- [Kelly] So you're gonna help take care
while they get a little, yeah.
- Oh my God!
(Kelly laughing)
The last time that she was at our house,
I fed her mushed banana.
- Yeah.
- In a spoon, with a spoon.
- [Kelly] It's magical.
- It is in my heart.
I'm telling you, it makes me
cry when I think about it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Wait, I wanna
talk about you more.
So you're on TikTok now?
- Okay.
Well, because of my granddaughter,
my older granddaughter.
- I know. So she, did
she force you to do that?
- 12 and nine.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- India and Lulu.
- Look at you!
- Oh my God!
(audience applauding)
- Oh, there they are!
- Oh my God!
- You must be the best grandpa ever.
- You are the best grandpa, I love it!
- I can't, I can't.
- And I got to say, at the very end,
it kinda looked like
you were twerking, sir.
(audience laughing)
- You know what?
If I get the chance, I will twerk.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- You know what? If the spirit
move within me, why fight it?
- The girls said, "Papa,
you have to be on TikTok."
And then they picked the music.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then they, one of them,
they're both dancers.
- Okay.
- Now, I mean truly gifted dancers
and they kind of pick what we're gonna do
and then, boom, we do it.
So the little one in the front is Lulu,
then is Ace.
Ace just turned 10, we took
him to Hamilton two weeks ago.
And then behind is India.
- Yeah.
- India is the choreographer.
- The choreographer.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Well you killed it.
- Thank you.
- You did.
I am not, I've never done a dance.
I don't feel like on TikTok,
have y'all done that yet?
- I refuse to join.
- I don't, I-
- I can't.
I cannot.
This is where I say no.
- This is my line, yeah.
- Remember this conversation?
I say no.
- I never thought I would,
but when-
- Your grandkids can
get you to do it,
- You were shamed into it,
you do it.
- No, that, you have to do it.
- You have to.
- Shame is a powerful tool.
- Yeah.
- And let me just say, 13 million views.
- No, it's insane.
(audience cheering)
- Well, hello!
- Yes sir.
(audience cheering)
- Oh! Oh my God!
- Yes sir.
(audience applauding)
- Wait, I thought we were
gonna get a reenactment.
- I know. No, 'cause I wanna know this.
I heard that you do magic.
- You know what? I have
a masters in magicology.
- So I heard, you were
saying that you do magic.
I didn't know this.
- I do.
I do magic.
- Really?
- It's in my fingers.
- Did you make up magicology?
Or is it a-
- No, I'm made it up.
- Okay, okay.
I feel like, wait-
- Not only did I make it up,
but I only do one trick.
- Okay, great.
You know what?
Then you're consistent.
- You wanna see it?
- Yes.
- Yes I do.
- I have the trick with me.
- Okay, you have the trick-
- I'll tell you where I learned it.
- You're about to just give me money?
- I had to learn it-
- I will make that disappear pretty fast.
- No, no. I can do that too.
I have money to give, everybody gets-
- Oh!
- Yes.
(Kelly laughing)
- Okay. Thank you.
- There you go.
(Kelly laughing)
All right.
- Okay.
- There you go.
- I mean, okay.
- Okay. So.
- What are we doing? Is
this part of the trick?
- This is not part of the trick at all.
You get to go out and
just have drinks together.
- Okay.
(Kelly laughing)
He's buying us drinks.
(audience applauding)
And in LA this shall buy one.
- Yeah.
- [Zosia] If that.
- Oh, here!
- What do I have here?
- You have a quarter.
- Okay. Is that a quarter?
- That's a quarter.
- All right, now listen very carefully.
- Okay.
(quarter clinking)
- Yeah, that's-
- Is that a quarter?
- That's a quarter
- Right?
That can't be my fingers.
- No.
- Okay. Here we go.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Magicology.
- Here we go.
(audience laughing)
(Henry blowing)
- Here we go.
- All right. Okay.
- What are you gonna swallow it?
- What? No!
- Oh.
- No.
Okay, now. One...
Okay. Count to three!
- [Kelly] Okay. One, two, three.
(Henry spitting)
- How did you do it? Wait, is it-
- How?
How?
(audience cheering)
- Magicology!
- I get the flowers.
- I get flowers.
Well, you know what?
I get the money.
- Yeah!
- So it's going in here.
- That's fine!
What do I do?
- Yeah, okay.
- So, okay, so wait.
Henry's current show is called "Barry"
and it's about a hit man.
- Yes.
- Who wants to become an actor?
- And Henry plays
the acting coach?
- Well, yes.
- Yes. Okay.
So what were acting classes like?
Like what were-
- Well, first of all,
every actor in that acting
class is a home run hitter.
One writer has now produced
and directed a show on Netflix.
- Oh, wow.
- Every one of them is
doing unbelievably well.
And in the third year
there are many changes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, if you
thought it was dark last year.
- Yeah.
- A dark comedy.
This year, I bought a
miners cap with a lamp.
(Kelly laughing)
- You're going in.
- Ooh.
- Light.
In the dark.
- 'Cause it was too dark.
- But I will say-
- Yeah.
- I feel like a lot of us
could have used that the
last two years of our lives.
- It's so true.
- Help me find the way out.
- But can I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- Do you feel like,
you've come a long way.
- Yeah.
- Right in that trauma.
- You did it!
- I'm still wading through a bit of it,
but yeah.
- I understand.
But the way you, come on-
- Yeah.
- You see the edge
of the river.
- No, 100%.
No, I didn't believe it at first.
And people were like,
"Oh, it's gonna be fine."
I'm like, this is what people just say.
- Right?
- Yeah.
That's a lie.
- But you're getting there.
- But no, no. It is true.
And it is one of those things
that I think that you have
to just get through though.
Like any kind of traumatic experience,
you unfortunately just
have to wade through it.
- Well, let me just say,
everybody who knows you, and watches you,
and read's about you,
is pulling for you to get
right up on that bank.
- Well, thank you.
(audience cheering)
That's really nice.
- Am I right?
(Zosia cheering)